right well the other radical 2020
Democratic candidate 1k so Marianne
Williamson she's under fire and attack
from other Democrats and she has
suddenly come to the realization that
the left and America's mean well we've
been pointing this out many times on
this show the left acts like it has
monopoly on compassion every day
unleashing an endless stream of vicious
vile comments they get away with it big
double standard you look at Hollywood
for example washed-up actor Jim Carrey
he's accusing Mitch McConnell being
worse than bin Laden and that comes
after actress Debra Messing earlier this
week wanted a blacklist all Trump
supporters in Hollywood naming all the
donors the reaction fox news contributor
dan bond Geno Fox News correspondent at
larger all the Rivera you know have are
you have you ever been Dan bungee no a
supporter of Donald Trump in other words
have you been a smelly Walmart shopper
like Hannity the are you an irredeemable
deplorable I'm proud to shop at Walmart
I'm proud to be called a deplorable and
yes I humbly cling to my god aren't my
guns for protection I believe in the
Bible and my religion in my faith yeah I
do guilty on all counts
yeah Marianne Williamson I mean I don't
know where she's been at me having run
for office I meet them Italy familiar
with the atrocious left and how they
treat conservatives but it's for a
reason Sean you know send us before but
it's worth the audience tuning in to and
listening to you know we think liberals
are people with really bad ideas but
liberals don't think the same of us they
think we're really bad people with ideas
there's a difference and that brings it
largely I mean there's exceptions
obviously but that's what brings out
this vitriol on both sides and I think
why Trump has them particularly heated
you saw that was ridiculous tweets by
Jim Carrey today Debra Messing and her
co-host I don't even remember the other
guy he will from willing growl don't
even know his real name but wanted black
lists from eric mccormack if he cuz it
they wanted black lists you know this is
real this has been going on for decades
and they just really really dislike us
in Trump won't back down and that
infuriates them even more and by the way
he did win on the
Walther although remember I said he's
changing strategies not giving up well
now he's promising to who wants 500
miles of that wall built 3.6 billion
yes reallocated as he said Eden promised
he would get done but overall how do you
assess these climate change fanatics
well I think that what it's very telling
is the Biden segment you did and Joe
friendly Joe lovable Joe committing gaps
its gaps it's a benign you know flub
it's not a really meaningful substantive
issue in terms case because in the
president's going to be there to me and
he looks like he has no energy well
maybe a thousand years since he left
office all that all that true but you
have the situation where he gets a pass
for making a mistake
president Trump on the other hand when
he makes a mistake it is either a lie or
he's stupid the there is a maliciousness
there's a malignancy in the criticism of
the president that does not exist the
other way around and I think that is
very unfortunate and very telling I call
myself roadkill
why I'm in the middle of the road I get
it from both sides and our late great
boss Roger Ailes you say the only thing
in the middle of Road was roadkill so I
understand that you know I think that
sometimes conservatives can be defensive
they can be L most embarrassed about
their ideology that's why they were
afraid about a boy boycott said no but
you are different you that's what you're
the new wave that fox news channel has
has really changed the playing fields
that regard some of them but they the
left they are though the criticism I get
for instance on the Left Arocha but from
the left I get that it's pretentious
it's smug it's arrogant they're smaller
than me you know they throw adverbs a
sleazy this or that you know it is it is
so this discomforting to me and so
angering to me that I hear these people
and what is no was it different every
year although this protection says I'll
tell you what the difference is and I
say this as a dear friend who respects
your coming up on your 50 years
doesn't had remarkable work in war zones
what you did at Willowbrook you you made
serious significant changes even your
fights on the center of the Geraldo show
is awesome but the differences is you
love the country you want the president
to succeed you might disagree on some
issues but you want the country to
prosper and you say it and you get one
at a time we get one president at a time
you know when he succeeds we all succeed
I think that there's a there's a time
for campaigning there's a time for
partisanship but there's also a time
where we're just Americans I mean these
calls these bitter calls for boycotts
and so forth I and Debra Messing you
know ask him for lensless and outing
people that it is it is the Joe McCarthy
it's the reverse it's the mirror image
of what happened in the nineteen fifties
it is as hateful now as it was then last
word to Dan you know I just never see
anything like it Shawn I mean I work out
in a relatively conservative gym and it
was a guy in there a few months ago with
an Obama shirt on and nobody said
anything to him yet we had a liberal guy
come in a few weeks ago he said hey is
that that guy from Fox News he better
keep his head down talking about me like
well I really pissed Trump bother you
that much you can't even work out in the
gym well that's some guy confronting you
it was really stupid they drew get a
grip left this not that big of a deal
go well let's see for dello my gym rat
friends have a lot of homes and you
you're you looked a lot more than I do
but I I have one advantage over your
damn bungee no and you know what it is
you'd be proud of me by the way I just
got out of an MMA class before I got on
the air just and I'm still sweating from
the class so I can't win you have my
respect